there was a big fan campaign to like
save the show Subway was one of our main
sponsors and even like product placement
tie-ins we had it on the show all the
time I liked it was a really good
product placement in that we just leaned
into it it was so like winking to the
audience how about that foot long but it
was really fun because there was a
Subway literally around the corner the
the the campaign was happening like
right then that weekend we had already
done one panel and and it wasn't that
small uh that big of a convention so
like everybody who was at the convention
who wanted to go to the panel basically
already saw the panel I said well what
if we just like what if we just like
instead of doing the panel what if we
just invited everybody to go to uh to
the subway and I did by the way the poor
people at Subway had we gave tried to
give them a heads up but they were still
not prepared for the amount of people
that were they were about to get hit
with and so it because it was moving as
slowly as it was I was like yo let me
let me get back there so I started
making sandwiches with the Sandwich
Artist by the way I became a sandwich
artist for today wow I know I know